foreign
hi okay welcome to another episode of
science and technology q a
for kids and others
i think we have a number of questions
left over from last
week let me see it's a question from ic
what is my opinion of the usability and
programmability of current computers in
comparison
to ones i've used in my life do i have
wishes
for future computers well okay
so i'm an old guy and i've been using
computers for a long time
i first saw a computer
when i was about 10 years old which is
around 1970 and
the first computer that i saw i barely
saw it it was in a room
sort of kind of tucked away and it had
lots of those uh you know spinning tape
drive
thingies that you see in old movies and
so on
and uh there were only very special
humans that were allowed to go anywhere
near the computer
that was a a big mainframe computer then
then
um the first computer that i actually
used myself was in 1972
um when i was 12 years old and that
computer
was um about the size of a large desk
and um i was fortunate that the
school that i was at um happened to have
managed to get this computer actually
one of the teachers there uh had been a
friend of alan turing's alan turing was
a big pioneer of computing
and somehow through that connection they
managed to get this computer
it was a computer that you can probably
find on the web it was called an elliott
903c made by a company called elliott
brothers
which i can assure you is no longer a uh
a computer company it was actually had
been a scientific instrument maker in
the late 1800s and they had got
themselves into computers
um in some collaboration with a company
called marconi
marconi was a company that uh was
started by the chap who first
commercialized radio
back around 1900 or so um but anyway
there was this computer
and um it was a computer about the size
of a desk
it um it had
eight uh 8 000 words of memory so modern
computers
uh usually they measure their memory in
bytes which is
eight binary bits and um usually a
word on a modern computer is 64 bits
or eight bytes um that's that's sort of
the basic unit of storage that
is used in programs um the uh the
computer that i used had um
8 000 words uh so modern computers like
the the
random laptop will probably have um
um at least a few gigabytes of memory
and you know if it's
a really big crunchy computer will be
hundreds of gigabytes that's some
uh so that would be in in terms of words
that might be
um uh well let's say a billion words
of um a memory the computer that i first
used had eight
000 words of of of memory
and somewhat exotically it had 18-bit
words
so normally these days you know uh
computer memory is
the sort of smallest unit people care
about is bytes which is eight bits
um and as i say words are usually 64
bits now
um the computer i used happened to have
rather exotically been engineered with
18-bit
uh words um and
uh you know how did you get a program
into the computer well
uh you used um usually paper tape
actually i might even have one of those
paper tapes now you see this is one of
these
can i you know what this is very
convenient well
this is a this is an actual prop there
we go there's an actual paper tape
from um uh from the first computer that
i used and it's
um you can see it has little holes
punched in it maybe you can see there
you go
you can see it has little holes punched
in it and those um
uh those represent the program
how did you read this paper tape well
there were two ways one was
you could put it in a device that would
have little little pins
and the tape would be moved through uh
and the pins would be pushed up where
there were
whether the holes are not pushed up with
their arms holes and that's the way it
would be read
the better way to read it was an optical
reader where you'd have a
light that shone through it and you'd
have a photoelectric cell
that would um uh would be on
when the light shone through one uh uh
when when there was a hole there and off
and it wasn't
and it would it would go pretty fast it
would go zipping through the the um
the reader one of the big skills in
those days was the
the tape when it had gone through the
reader would end up in this big
wooden bin and then you would have to
rewind the tape
by putting it on some some winder thing
and turn it around and the trick was
don't tear the tape when you rewind the
tape
anyway this is a this is a program that
i wrote for that computer
um it's written in a very low level
well it's written in uh assembler um
essentially the intrinsic code of the
machine
so that that machine had 16 instructions
so at the at the lowest level in most
computers like your average um
i don't know mac or pc or whatever um
the the lowest level instructions that
go into the
the the typically into the alu part of
the cpu of the computer
there'll be a few hundred kinds of
instructions that say things like
uh load this thing into this location in
memory
add these two numbers together do this
do that do the other thing
so that the computer that that uh that
used this paper tape
had 16 instructions and um they they had
literally numbers like the four
instruction was
load the accumulator of the computer
which was a register in the in the
uh a place where you could so you could
say and now this is
outrageous that i can still remember all
of this stuff but you could say things
like four plus zero
meant load zero into this register in
the cpu of the computer
or you could say um let's see a sixth
instruction was a subtract
and a um uh well um
if you said anyway it had a bunch of
these instructions i think it would be
too weird and boring to tell you what
they all were
and the fact is i don't think i've
thought about them in in
in solidly 45 years so
um but i think i can remember them all
um anyway that was that was my my first
computer it actually
ran comparably fast it was like a a um
every instruction took about a
microsecond to run
um millionth of a second to run had a
nice feature the computer had a nice
feature that it actually made a sound
when it ran
and so you could tell what it was doing
it would go you know it would you would
you would you could you could like hear
the program running and when
when the program ran until it was in
some tight loop where it was just
keeping on running the same instructions
it would have this high-pitched wine
when it was doing more complicated
things it would have different sounds
that's one of the features that's
gone missing in the intervening years
but anyway that was that was my very
first computer
um i then uh most of the kind of serious
computers people used in those days
were not computers that a mere human
could walk up to
and do things with they were mostly uh
only touched by sort of specialists
in in sort of uh tending the computer it
was a very kind of
um it's like uh like like you kind of
imagine in ancient greece or something
the people
the priests and the temple type thing um
were the only ones who were actually
allowed to touch the computer
and i think um uh the um the thing that
um
um
the computer the elliott 903 computer
that that i used um
i think it's its main use was in um
i think it was used in tanks and things
like that it was used in um
various military applications uh it was
not a particularly particularly
successful
line of computers but um then
within a few years i i started using
kind of bigger computers
uh so-called mainframe computers usually
ibm 360
type computers that was a computer
family that had arisen in the 1960s
and um had was sort of the dominant kind
of computer that people used for serious
computations
the shocking fact is there are companies
that
wrote programs for ibm mainframes in the
1960s
and those same programs are still
running today and sometimes they've been
running without stopping
and the companies that do for example
things like credit card
transaction processing and things but
they've been running the same program
since that time and they go to
tremendous trouble to have the computer
never stop because if it stops you can't
settle the transactions or whatever else
so it's kind of a weird thing but but
those those kinds of computers
uh the um the typical mode of
interacting for example
when i was like 16 years old or
something 1976
i worked at a government lab in england
which had a
place called the rutherford lab which
had a big computer lots of big computers
actually
and the mode of interacting with them
was you would
write your program on cards um
you would so the cards were instead of
this paper tape which has which has
holes punched in it and
a card i'm sure i have a card somewhere
but i don't think i can find it
immediately
um the uh uh the cards
would be um you you have a card punch
machine
and you would type what you needed for
the on the on on each card and it would
come out in holes in the card
and each card was 80 characters across
80 columns across and that's why
sometimes when you see in modern
computers things are 80 characters
that comes because of cards um but
anyway you would you'd
type a card and you press a button and
the card would get sort of
taken out of the machine and put in a
big pile of cards and so your program
will be a big pile of cards and then you
would uh
the way it worked um you would sort of
hand put your cards in this pigeon hole
wooden pigeon hole type thing
and then somebody would go from the
other side from the kind of computer
side
they would take your cards and they
would somehow magically run your program
on the computer
and then they would give you back a
printout you know
printed by on on on paper by the
computer and put it back in your pigeon
hole and that was the um
that was the main mode of interacting
with the computer and if you were lucky
that process would take i don't know
half an hour an hour a couple of hours
something like that if there was a bug
in your program
it was very frustrating because there
would be a whole long cycle
of getting um of getting that um that
done again
and i think the um um it was
so that was sort of a typical mode of
interaction with computers as you
you hand it to the druids or something
that actually dealt with the computer
i'm not sure if they were still wearing
white coats at that time but they might
have been
um and uh they would sort of run your
program
and then uh get it back to you actually
by the next year
um 1977 i went to the u.s government lab
um and uh that was a time when i guess
for some reason they actually trusted
the scientists to be near the mainframe
computer
and so that was a case where that was
again an ibm 370 i think
computer um where you could actually
you like me could actually be with the
computer
in the same room and you could uh like
feed the cards in yourself and you know
there were all these flashing lights and
tapes and things like that
um but uh you could actually sort of
interact directly with the computer and
and the debugging cycle got a lot
shorter at that time although my
my all-time favorite of of of that was
that um
you know you would get you would you put
your
your cards in you would run your program
something would come back
and there would usually be these error
codes if there was something wrong
and i remember there was one i think it
was ieh0321
something i'm making up those numbers
slightly but it's roughly that
um and it's like what is this error and
there's these big manuals big books of
you know error codes for the computer
and so i look it up i look it up and
there's all these pages and pages of
error codes and all kinds of things
finally get to the error code that i had
and what did it say
it had only three words probable user
error
what on earth were all the other errors
well they were all things that might
have gone wrong with the computer
not things that were probably use the
error like your code is wrong
um so anyway that was a that's i
sometimes use that as an example
for people writing uh software
documentation of a
of a very unhelpful kind of thing to
have happen
in any case the the um uh
you know i think at that time it still
was the case that the majority that the
the results of um of your computing
were on paper they were printed by a
line printer
line printed just meant that it was
printing a whole line of characters at a
time
um chunk big um machine that just
printed these
on this paper i'm sure i've got a sample
of it someplace here
um that uh and so those were the results
now um you know then gosh i'm telling
you a whole
history of my um sort of story with
computers but but
um maybe for some people who are perhaps
younger it's like
there were computers before the way they
are today
um i think that um uh
well for me the um
the the next sort of big step of these
things called mini computers
a mini computer cost only
in those days probably 19 late 1970s
only a quarter million dollars
um and as opposed to which in today's
money would be i don't know million
dollars maybe
um and uh uh it was
only the size of i don't know
um several large desks usually built up
a lot higher
um and uh usually those um
and so i i first um had kind of very
direct access
kind of was sort of responsible for one
of those machines
back in probably 1979 1980
that was a a vax 11780 made by a company
called digital equipment corporation or
dec
which at the time was the world's second
largest computer company
um and uh after ibm um and i'm afraid
you know it's it's a sad feature of the
of the world of technology and commerce
that i'm not sure most people ever heard
of dec
anymore um and i know uh their
headquarters
were near where i live in in
massachusetts
uh they were in a town called maynard
massachusetts and uh it was a few years
ago that they had a giant factory thing
there
and it was demolished so it was uh
uh you know it's it's kind of a the
story that story is gone
but um the the next sort of big thing
that happened
um when for that computer for example
the um oh yeah actually i forget even
even even when i was using the computer
at the relevant lab
they had these things called which used
to be called vdus
visual display units which meant instead
of
always just typing your stuff on cards
you could actually have a visual display
of your programs and other things
interacting with the computer and you
could use a time-shared computer system
which meant that it's kind of like the
cloud today
it meant that instead of you just
writing your program sort of offline
you would um you know you would write
them as um
uh you would you would do things where
you use the text editor
and you typed um you you typed onto this
with files which could be displayed on
this on this visual display unit
um and usually those were 80 characters
across by 24 characters down
and they had individual characters it
wasn't like the modern displays bitmap
displays
where every pixel can be separately
colored red or green or whatever
these were just there was uh it was a
made with a
a crt um uh like an old-fashioned
television
and the electron beam in the thing went
as
big thing and the electron beam would go
uh
from the the source at the back and
eventually it would hit the screen and
light up
the screen and the the uh the pattern in
which it would light up the screen
was determined by the electron beam had
been routed through the so-called
character
they basically they would have a a mask
where they look
the shapes of the characters there and
depending on where the beam
was set it would go through the place
where there was an
a uh sort of template or a b template or
whatever and then
be sent to the screen and that's how it
would generate all the characters on the
screen
um anyway so that was that was kind of
the um uh the mechanism and there was
starting to be these time shared
operating systems where
lots of people could connect the same
computer and um you could you could do
these things um
uh interactively like that in fact i for
for a long time i
i am by by the late 1970s i
i was in the u.s and then i used to use
that
vax 11780 and i was usually
um because you could have this this uh
terminal
um sort of separated from the computer
uh one thing you could do was
uh you know just take the terminal home
and connect to the computer how did you
connect to the computer were you
connected through phone lines
how did you connect to the phone lines
used an acoustic coupled modem
so what that meant was you know the
phone is used to sending voice and so on
but it had been figured out how to send
you know weird tones and so on that
represented the data
that you were trying to send from the
computer but the technology
was you literally you took a phone the
handset
phone with a big you know big
old-fashioned you know
wired phone with a big handset and you
literally take the handset
and put it into this object that had
these rubber cups
where you know there was the speaker the
speaker and the microphone
were you know put into those two rubber
cups and if you pull the thing out just
a little bit you could hear it whistling
uh you could hear the computer sending
data receiving data by
by making different whistling sounds and
usually that was going at about 30
characters per second
was was a typical speed and then it
increased to about um
uh what was it about 100 characters a
second um
so actually i was very impressed with
the american phone system because i
i am i connected one of those and i i
just left it connected for like six
months
um you know by at my house and and just
just uh you know had had the thing
connected to the acoustic couple modem
and it didn't drop any bits it was it
was just sat there
um and uh you know i don't know maybe i
did something terrible to the phone
system by doing that but um
it um it seemed to work rather well but
anyway then
after that kind of the next evolution
was um well actually my first company
was a software company
started in 1981 um
one of the one of the goofy things that
was done by the management that i
brought in
was they had the idea gosh our software
has a hard time running on the current
generation of hardware
we'll um uh you know we'll build our own
hardware to be able to run the software
and i was like this is a very bad idea
um there were all kinds of reasons why
that was very difficult but
it just so happened at that time i
happened to visited uh stanford
university once and i
was a chat uh shows me this this
computer in kind of a cardboard box
that is a was called the stanford
university network
computer s-u-n computer um
uh subsequently became called the sun
workstation there was a company called
sun that
is now uh part of oracle um
that sort of pioneered this idea of
so-called workstation computers
which were intended to be things that
were used by a single person
as kind of a you know a thing that they
would actually do computations right
there
uh you know for themselves so to speak
on their own computer rather than
sending it to some central computer
and they also had bitmap displays that
is displays where
um you could put arbitrary uh pixels
on the on the screen and so on and that
um those sort of came into existence by
maybe 1983 84 ish
there are a number of companies that
sort of competed in that market i mean
meanwhile there were
personal computers um the uh the apple
ii had come out in 1978 or so even i
think
um then um then the pc came out
um and uh um then the
the mac came out in 1984 famously
um and uh but those computers for me
as a kind of a user of of sort of more
serious some
computing things i i never really use
those kinds of computers
i used um i tried to get portable
computers
there was a company called compaq i
think now part of dell
that made a very early portable computer
it was no actually the very first one i
i had was made by a company called
osborne
there's a computer called the osborne
one it was about the size of a small
suitcase
and you could uh but it was portable you
could pick it up you could carry it
around
it was kind of an interesting adventure
carrying it through los angeles
international airport
as probably one of the first portable
computers that had been seen on an x-ray
machine
um it was also interesting um
figuring out that like if you flew on a
747 plane there was a
there was an outlet right at the back of
the plane there's just one outlet where
you could plug the computer in because
it didn't have batteries
it took way too much power but that
computer for example
was um used floppy disks um and uh it
used
um an operating system called cpm which
was a
rather primitive operating system um and
uh really you could do a little bit of
word processing on it but that was about
all that i could use it for
um and uh anyway i'm i think i'm giving
a very long answer to this
this question but um uh you know by
by sometime in the um uh in the in the
uh early 80s i was kind of using these
workstation computers and
and honestly the fundamentally the
configuration of of
what's sort of on my desk isn't much
different i mean the screen's gotten
bigger
um the computer's gotten faster at least
it did for a while
um the uh the operating system has
gotten sort of smoother but the idea of
having windows on a screen and so on
you know i was already using those kinds
of things by by the
early 1980s um and uh you know sometimes
i would uh
all these ideas like when i first saw i
think probably around 1979 1980 i first
seen the idea of windows on a screen
it's like you can't be serious there are
situations where you're trying to get a
file from here to there
where you're trying to drag it from one
part of the screen to the other and
another window is obscuring it and
you know you're not going to be able to
do it you have to move these windows
like a physical
thing to be able to move these files and
i thought this is just going to be a
killer
miss feature but it's turned out well
it's kind of annoying every time i every
time that happens to me
so i just can't drag the file because
the drag location
you know drag destination is obscured on
the screen i kind of think back to the
fact that i thought this was never going
to work at all
but it's obviously worked much better
than we expected but back in those days
um you know i could talk a little bit
about how one program computers in those
days
um uh you know first well
uh you know but the main conclusion was
that i needed to build my own tools for
for using computers and that's kind of
what got me started on building computer
languages
and computational languages and and all
these kinds of things
um i can uh um
uh can talk about that more but but
maybe i should um
um uh well i mean i should say that
it's always interesting you know when
you've sort of been around the computer
industry and computer technology for a
long time
it is amusing the extent to which people
say oh my gosh there's this new thing
we're now doing this and it's like
actually
that was something everybody did 25
years ago you've just forgotten
so for example the move to cloud
computing is is just the same story as
the whole time sharing story
from back come uh back in the distant
past
um and um it's uh uh and even you know
for example i first had email in 1976
um and um there were computer networks i
used to use
the arpanet which is a early predecessor
of the internet
and i used that starting in 1976. there
were only
whatever 256 computers on the on the
arpanet at that time
um and each one had a number and so on
but it was still
sort of the same idea as today but this
this trend
between sort of are you going to do it
locally are you going to do your
computing locally on your local machine
are you going to do it on a big distant
machine that trend has been going back
and forth
for at least 50 years um of you know is
it is it local
is it remote and it's really a question
of the relative uh you know how fast is
the computer
how fast is the communication channel
how much stuff are you trying to send
back and forth
how well can you predict what has to be
sent you know if it's a movie
you kind of know in advance you're going
to watch the next five minutes so you
might as well
pre-load that and so on those kinds of
things
um you know it's always interesting to
see these different
styles of computing that become popular
and i think uh uh you know everybody's
been waiting for virtual reality and
augmented reality and so on
i remember first seeing i first probably
used a vr system
probably late 1980s and everybody said
it's almost here
you know something where you can uh
where you can kind of see the um
uh you have the head mounted display and
so on and you can kind of
get a realistic view of the visual scene
um well it's still not here now
you know will that be a way that i
choose to use computers you know i have
to say apart from the fact that
i have tried using vr for some of the
things i've been doing in our physics
project
i get a little bit um i still get a
little bit seasick
motion sick or something when i use
these things um that will probably
improve as as some of the tracking gets
better
um for those kinds of devices but but
you know it will be an interesting time
when there's a very different way to
to write programs and so on that's a
really different environment from the
one that
basically i've been using since since
the early 1980s of
you know windows on a screen etc um
and uh you know i've been trying to
build um
a sort of computational language that
brings us to a much higher level
of of what we can expect to do in
interacting with a computer
hasn't really affected the um it's
affected greatly what i say to the
computer but not
kind of how i say it in terms of of
typing things in
and and so on probably much more to say
about that but let me i want to get to
some more of these um
um uh these questions here
let's see
um
boy there's a question from pranjul here
how can we fix the shortcomings and
comings of current neural net
architectures well gosh
so first point is you know there's this
whole
area of machine learning which has
become very popular in the last few
years i would say that it
it really started to become super
popular around 2012
um and i think it's probably its
popularity is a little bit
you know it's flattened off at this
point um and there are lots of kinds of
things where people said you'll never be
able to get a computer to do that like
recognize you know what kind of bird am
i showing you a picture of
and then that's now become pretty easy
how did that work
well the way it works is you're using
mostly these things called neural nets
and what you're doing is you're showing
it a whole bunch of pictures of this
kind of bird whole bunch of pictures of
that kind of bird
and it's kind of learning uh what
these different kinds of birds look like
and then when you show it a new picture
of a bird it's saying that looks like
this thing that i learned before
how does that learning work what's
happening is you're basically trying to
translate your
those pictures that initially get
translated into a big array of numbers
each picture they're kind of like just
the the colors of the pixels on the
screen that represent that that picture
and then what you're doing is you're
figuring out how to
kind of um how how to uh
if you if you look at all the arrays of
numbers that represent a
um an eagle for example and all the
arrays of numbers that represent a
swallow
you're um you're going to um
what you've got to do is to figure out
what's in common between the arrays of
numbers that represent eagles and
different
from what represents i don't know a a a
parrot let's say
um and uh uh there's a fairly
efficient method that's now known to uh
to try and figure that out and it's
based on neural networks
neural networks were sort of loosely
based on the way brains do things you
know in our brains
we've got about 100 billion neurons
neurons are these these cells in our
brain that
uh basically they either fire and
produce an electrical signal
every millisecond or every few few
thousand times a second
or they don't and they're like either on
or off more of us they have these spike
trains that they produce
but roughly you can say are they on or
are they off and every neuron
might be connected to let's say a
hundred or even a thousand other neurons
and it's saying were you on were you off
and it's looking at the pattern of which
other neurons that it's connected to
we're on and off
and then it's deciding am i going to be
on on the next the next moment or not
that's kind of how our brains work and
and
neurons were originally discovered by um
a microscopist named romano cajao around
1900
looking at actual um actual brains
noticed that there were these cells
these neurons and it sort of became
clear that the brain was this kind of
arrangement of
of connected uh neurons then in 1943 i
think
um a chap called warren mcculloch and a
chap called walter pitts
um basically figured out this kind of
theoretical mathematical framework
to describe how neural networks might
work
and the big thing they did was to show
that given something that could be
thought of as a bunch of
these sort of objects that were either
on or off and they were connected
by sort of wire-like things to other
objects that could be on or off
that you could uh emulate a sort of
another mathematical model of a computer
a turing machine and and you could show
that this kind of neural net thing
could compute anything that this other
model of a computer could compute
at the time there weren't yet digital
electronic computers
but as soon as there were it became
clear that these neural net things
could be where they could be emulated on
a digital computer and they could in
principle emulate what a digital
computer could do
people were still very confused about
whether brains
could somehow more do more than digital
computers can do
but at least this mcculloch pits model
of neural networks
was like mathematically it was it's the
same story as what a standard computer
can do
well for a long time a long long time
decades and decades
people would use neural nets and they
would use them for various toy things
they would study them and they would do
science with them
and they would try and compare them with
brains and they didn't really compare
very well and they were
like they tried to do things with them
and they tried to do early
optical character recognition which went
fairly well of saying
is that an a b or a c when as as pixels
on the screen
and they would try and solve these
problems like is that a an eagle or a
parrot and that would fail
um and it kept on failing and back
around 1980
i i did a bunch of work with neural
networks actually and i tried to figure
out you know
what would they do could they do
anything interesting and i was like no
they can't really do anything
interesting
well then in 2011 sort of almost by
mistake
it was realized that a sort of a bigger
neural net
if you just let it take look at a large
number of examples
and kind of grind around trying to
arrange itself internally
and grind around for maybe a month of
computer time
magically somehow the thing would figure
out how to arrange itself so that it
could correctly recognize those new
examples coming in
and so suddenly at that time the idea of
so-called deep learning
the deep comes from the fact that there
are many layers inside this neural net
and they all have to kind of arrange
their numbers in order to make the thing
work
um and it takes a long time to arrange
the thumbs you have to go through this
whole elaborate
training procedure which can take you
know sometimes
uh years of computer time although it
can be
done somewhat in parallel so it's not uh
not not taking quite as much
real time but it can take it can take
huge amounts of time to do that training
but the remarkable thing is that it's
turned out that it actually works fairly
well
it works very well on certain kinds of
tasks basically when you have a task
where it's not
really a super precise thing it's like
is this an eagle
is this a parrot okay you know well it's
kind of a clue that you're showing it in
a jungle background it's more likely to
be a parrot
it's kind of a clue that the eagle is
next to the you know the blue sky
whatever
oh it gets it wrong some fraction of the
time but it's getting it more or less
right
there are many tasks that we humans do
where getting things more or less right
is super useful
um there are other tasks like i don't
know
doing mathematical computation where to
get it only roughly right
is kind of useless um there are other
tasks and
plenty of tasks for getting it only
roughly right is kind of useless
but um uh but but in any case this sort
of getting it roughly right thing and
tasked with getting it roughly right
is is is fine um
there are lots of them image
identification is one uh voice
transcription that is you know when you
talk to
you know your siri or some or alexa or
something and um
uh it figures out what did you say and
it turns that into text and maybe it
sends it on to waltham alpha or
something
um it um uh that process
if it gets some word wrong occasionally
it's not a disaster
and that's another place where neural
networks do very well um
similarly being able to pick things out
in videos that's another kind of place
where they do very well
these kinds of things where it's like
well you know you get it more or less
right and that's good enough they do
very well
and what's really happened last few
years is that as
things neural nets get more efficient
you can you know first you could do
single images then you could do
audio now you'd be doing video
reasonably well
um these things that steadily sort of
gets better
and you figure out more and more tasks
where it makes sense to get a result
that's roughly right
now in terms of you know will you be
able to do magic things so one thing
that gets very popular
that they're usually these little bursts
of enthusiasm for different kinds of
things so one
that's that's happening right now is
text generation
so you can say you know write me a story
about whatever
and it will just go and generate the
story well it's kind of okay
but if you really say if you say how
well did you really do that
you know what's the way of grading it
you get somebody to say will this essay
get an a a b or a c
if it was graded as something you send
in to you know for school or something
um but uh that's not usually done and
usually it's like well it's kind of cool
it kind of looks pretty good
but it's really hard to know you know
did it do great or did it do terribly
and the fact is it's going to do okay
but i'm not sure that task is a
is a terrific one there's a there's a
version of that task which is language
translation
going from you know french to english or
something um
where where again it's like if you get
it roughly right
that's good enough you know occasionally
you're gonna get it wrong but it's still
super useful
to even get it roughly right and and uh
that's something that's that's
kind of gotten to a pretty good level uh
you know
it it works better when there's more
stuff to train
the neural network on so for example for
european languages
uh the european union for for all of its
adventures
one thing that it's done is that
whenever there's some sort of uh
government document it gets translated
into all the languages that are used in
the european union
so there are these pieces of text that
exist
in gazillions of languages i don't know
how many it is 20 languages or something
is it that many
i don't know 15 whatever um and that
means that when you want if you want to
train a computer
to say i want to translate from german
to french to english to whatever
um i wonder if they're going to drop
english no no i think not there's still
english-speaking countries
in the eu um but any case the the um
that allows you to have billions of
words of training data
for um uh for language translation but
um you know in terms of of um uh
what will be the kind of um the end
point of sort of neural net things
people it's interesting to figure out
you know if you could do much better
training what could you train the neural
net to do
and there are some additional tasks you
can imagine doing but in terms of um
some other tasks which have been getting
better unbelievably slowly so one task
is
uh conversation so for instance back in
the 1960s
there was a thing called the liza which
was a a
kind of a uh sort of fake um
kind of counsellor psychiatrist type
thing where you would
you would type to it and it would say
you know
you would say um uh i don't know
it would say you know um
what color shirt are you wearing today
or something i'm not sure it would ask
those kinds of questions and it would
say
you know i'm wearing a i don't even know
what color this is
a white shirt and then it would say it
would be sort of come back and say does
it bother you that you're wearing a
white shirt
and it would try and have this kind of
conversation and it used very very
simple rules to do that
people found it kind of fun and then we
kind of go forward
you know 50 years and we say well what
do the conversation systems that we have
today what are they able to do
well you know with wolf and alpha we're
able to answer all kinds of questions
about the real world that's a
that's a remarkable thing that that you
know wasn't clear it's going to be
possible i mean we
we did that now 10 years ago or more um
and you know
by you know encoding a lot of knowledge
computationally it's a whole story about
how that was done
but um that's that's sort of a answer
questions about the world
but if it's just like have a nice chat
um
and and do it in a way that this really
seems intelligent
that's still really difficult um you
know one can
one can have some things that do a good
job at a sort of play level
but um in terms of really doing it and
having having a real
conversation with content that's really
pretty hard to do and that's that's been
a thing that hasn't really been achieved
yet
um i think that um uh in terms of the
the details of um how neural nets work
inside i mean i can go into arbitrary
levels of technical detail about that
but
let me not do that um let me say that i
think
the um uh there are sort of assumptions
about how
how they work that basically make use of
calculus in very fundamental ways
that probably are neither necessary nor
efficient and
there are probably ways of doing things
with with simpler programs
that don't make use of calculus but they
need to make use of new
kind of ideas for how you kind of search
through a space of programs
and i've sort of worked on those things
for years and we don't really know the
answer how to do that yet
um and perhaps we will finally figure
that out in fact some of the spin-offs
from our physics project
might be suggesting ideas about how to
do that
but we don't know that yet and that's
that's the kind of um the sort of buzz
term there will be things like cellular
automata
and connecting those to neural nets that
there's a very different kind of thing
um and uh uh that that's kind of a
a potential future direction
um
oh boy there's a question from just
noises
how does hitting a bucket of water on
the side with a tennis ball make the
water surface splash
with plenty of tiny droplets which grow
very high but hitting it with the same
force with one's foot
makes the water move as a big lump which
doesn't splash
is this analogous the photoelectric
effect okay
splashes splashes are a complicated
thing
there was a chap an uncle worthington i
think
who had a classic book called the study
of splashes
and um that was uh made possible
a splash happens very quickly so
what made it possible to study this was
the invention of flash photography
the invention of of uh you know you have
a camera
it opens its shutter it's you know in
old days it was exposing
film um but uh then you know bright
flash of light
it only picks up an image when there's
that bright flash of light
and by by having that flash of light be
very short
period of time you could like freeze a
frame
this is all easy to do now but it wasn't
back in the day
you could freeze a frame for a
thousandth of a second or something you
could just capture
what happened in a thousandth of a
second so you would see things like you
know bursting a balloon you would see
the little
cracks forming in the surface of the
rubber because you could freeze that
frame by having a very
quick flash and that's the only thing
the camera will be sensitive to so back
in
i think 1908 as i remember correctly
this chap called worthington made this
study of splashes
so what happens when there's a splash
drop something in water you drop a
turns out it matters what shape the
thing is that you drop in the water
but let's say you drop a sphere in the
water i think that's the one that's been
mostly dropper you drop a drop of water
in the water so what does a splash look
like a lot of weird things that happen
so one thing that happens is the water
goes down
and it produces this kind of um uh
so-called corona
looks like a crown you get this circle
of water
and there's a circle and around so in
the in the middle
the thing you know hits the water in the
middle and the water comes up
around the sides and the water seems
like it's just coming up in this film
and this kind of crater-like thing
that's just uniformly coming up on each
side
but it doesn't do that instead the water
which would usually be just this
this this circle of water it breaks up
um into into little little drops
and it forms this kind of crown like
shape where you see the little drops
forming around the thing so you might
have 10 drops around the circumference
of the circle
um a so-called corona effect
and um so that's that's one weird thing
the weird thing that happens is right in
the center of the water the waters come
down
and then the water comes back up it kind
of bounces back and you'll have this
kind of
tube of water that comes up and you
actually often have a little drop at the
top of that tube it's as if
as if the drop the thing you dropped in
had bounced back
and made a drop of water very weird
effects
okay what causes these effects so the
main effect
um that causes that this sort of thing
that would otherwise be kind of a
regular
sort of circle or cylinder of water on
the outside to break into this sort of
crown
uh what are they called the things on a
crown
um what are they called my gosh um
uh anyway the the the points on the
crown so to speak
um the uh coronets no that's not right i
don't know
any case the um not a word that i use
very often
um in any case the the um
uh so-called rayleigh taylor instability
that causes
um the uh uh that causes the thing to
break up why does it break up
so it breaks up because of a phenomenon
called surface tension
and um so okay what's the story here so
if you have something like water
water has a certain
that the surface of the water will
always try to be
as as small an area as possible so if
you have a
blob of water let's say you're on the in
the space station where things are
weightless
so water doesn't fall to the ground just
get some water
what shape does the water make the water
will make a sphere
because the sphere is the thing which
encloses a certain volume
and has the minimum area there will be a
surface tension
that tries to pull to tries to make the
water form something which has the
minimum surface area
it's a big problem apparently on the on
the space station that you get these
blobs of water that is hanging around
all over the place because they don't
fall to the ground they just blob around
there
um and uh anyway but but um so if left
to its own devices
water will for example if if water is
falling in a stream
it will form uh it might be falling a
continuous stream but
the stream will tend to break up into
these drops as a result of surface
tension
um and so that's what's happening in the
in the circumference of a splash
is you're forming drops because surface
tension is causing this water
to instead of being sort of this
continuous band of water it's breaking
it up into these things which are just
these little drops
so that that's that's the main effect
that causes
sort of splashes to be splashy so to
speak and have all these different
pieces
is is this is this instability due to
surface tension
um now um
uh i think this question
about um uh
you know this question about exactly
what shape that you get from different
ways to kind of hit a you know a bucket
of water or something
those are difficult things to work out
it's only in the last probably 10 years
that there's been decent ability to to
do mathematical models on a computer
and work out the kind of configurations
that um
uh that things like water will make i
mean there are and it's still
a bit of a like you know to what extent
does splashes depend on gravity
you know what do splashes look like um
on
uh you know in space um i don't fully
know the answer to this
people i've been i've tried for a while
to get some astronauts to really try
this out
and they're like we really don't want to
do that because when we make when when
you throw a big blob of water at
something on the space station for
example
it'll shatter into lots of different
drops and then we have to go vacuum up
all those drops
otherwise those drops will just get all
over the place because they don't
fall to the ground it's not like you end
up with a puddle of water on the floor
you end up with little
little drops embedded in some you know
in some instruments somewhere
and it's a big big nuisance so nobody
wants to have a splash
um in uh in in weightless
conditions because because you have to
clean up a lot of mess
so so anyway that's a little bit of a
story about splash
you know the the general phenomenon of
instabilities in fluids it's a
it's a fairly ubiquitous phenomenon it
causes
all kinds of elaborate um uh things in
the atmosphere in our atmosphere in the
atmosphere of planets like jupiter
for example if you look at even the
nuclear explosion that's happening
really really quickly
famous picture um uh from very very
early
i forget maybe millisecond thousandth of
a second maybe less
of the of the first nuclear explosion
shows this amazing
you might think the nuclear explosion
will just go boom and and um
make a spherical uh uh sort of object
but it doesn't
it has an instability and you see these
these weird shapes
that form even at after a very short
amount of time
as a result of of a phenomenon a little
different actually that's the um
that's the really taylor instability and
i may have the other one the one for
splashes might be just a pure rayleigh
instability
um the uh uh in any case
that these phenomena that that that
cause fluids
to become unstable in various ways and
same thing happens when you have fluid
turbulence
you just have a fluid flowing quickly
it's making all those little eddies and
so on that that's happening in the same
same kind of way but but slightly
different physics of what's going on
so question here from slayer what
sources do you use in keeping up with
science
news um
oh gosh i don't know i'm i'm not um
um somehow i seem to hear about things
but i'm not sure i'm that systematic i
i think there are a few magazines that
i've subscribed to the one that is
um there's one nice one called science
news which is a nice
um nice digest of um of recent science
some
uh science things but usually
it's um there's certain kinds of science
where it's like
we saw a new kind of limous in
madagascar and it looks like this and
that's kind of a
who what when where you know cut and
dried kind of science
it's not you know there's this big new
idea in some mathematical area it's more
like
this thing happened we can write about
it it's a story
um one magazine that i have to say i've
subscribed to for more than 50 years
is a magazine called new scientist it's
a british science magazine
i'm impressed that it's been going for
that long um it's a kind of popular
science magazine
i i always enjoy it because it's it's
full of um it's full of kind of uh
slightly uh edgy scientific news
and and i have to say one feature of um
of new scientists is is sometimes
there's it's sort of a little bit the
kiss of death for some kinds of science
that if if if it was written about there
it probably won't become real
and there's a tremendous tendency of of
articles to end
with you know the people who describe
this say it could
lead to such and such a thing but it's
really interesting in terms of just
ideas about different um uh different
random
pieces of science that people are
exploring often more outlandish kinds of
things
so i certainly enjoy that i mean there
are much better systematic sources
um you know i have kind of have the
unfair feature or advantage that
i you know i have a fairly large team
that i work with
and i know lots of people in the kind of
scientific world and people tend to tell
me about stuff that
that they think i'll find interesting
and i
uh you know i'll i'll read lots of
things but i'm not
a i'm not as good a systematic uh
consumer of
of um of sort of science news as
i might be
um
let's see
okay there's a question from kareem
saying
that 12 years old how do you
set about like doing things like getting
phd in physics by the time you're 20 and
so on
um and uh
well i think uh
you know a couple of things to say
you know there's a certain amount of
learning the mechanics
of how to do science and calculate
things and
and all those kinds of things i think
the most interesting path
tends to be you know what do you want to
figure out
what questions are you trying to ask
there's a certain
you can get a certain distance by just
knowing how to answer
every exercise in the book but to go
further than that
you have to kind of figure out what
exercise would you put there
that they didn't think of putting there
or they didn't put there
you know what what question do you kind
of find really interesting that you can
kind of
attack i would also say that that um
in terms of modern times you know tools
are really worthwhile things to learn
both intellectual tools and more
practical kinds of
tools by that i mean like for example
you know our wolfram language
system uh you know i've spent most of my
life
trying to you know make that the best
tool i can
for figuring out things like things in
science
and uh you know people who know how to
program well
in that can just do amazing magic things
that um uh that other people are just
like oh my gosh how did you do that
i mean i think my um uh my youngest son
christopher happened to learn
programming in that
when he was probably nine or ten years
old or something
he's very fast he's faster than i am at
writing code and i'm always amused that
um
what was he showing me just a few days
ago i mean
just all kinds of different um uh
different things where you just take
some piece of data about the world
oh that's right he figured out for the
college he's at he was like
there's a 10-minute job of figuring out
you know what's the distribution of
which courses are being
the correlation between departments and
which course is being taught online or
not
you know that's a that's a a sort of a
it's an easy piece of data science if
you know how to do it
um and uh uh you know i think the the
the thing is
to to understand kind of the um
uh uh these tools and be really
proficient with them
so that you know once you have an idea
you can as directly as possible go from
the idea to yeah i can write piece of
code
you know type type type then something
happens you get a result
you think about it and so on and you
kind of iterate
inventing things that's a that's a
really critical thing
i mean the other thing is kind of more
intellectual tools of you know what
methods and ideas do you learn in modern
times there's just
tremendous uh you know the sort of the
the strongest
paradigm of our time is kind of
computation and just like in the past
it's like learn all those very elaborate
mathematical things
those are cool and those are worth
learning but really being able to be
proficient with all these computational
ideas
that's going to be the future of pretty
much every field including physics for
example
um and i think that the um uh
uh you know i would say that in terms of
you know do you do you push really hard
to do things uh you know to
go through school when you're really
young if you can do it easily
sure why not um but it depends i mean
you know for me i was really interested
in doing research
and so on and i got to the point where i
was doing that
pretty well by by the time i was i don't
know probably
14 or so and um it's like i can do what
i want to do
so let me just go ahead and get to the
point of being able to do it
you know do it for a living so to speak
as quickly as possible
uh you know i um at the time i was
mostly interested in do physics research
that was the thing i was interested in
and you know i think one of the things
that's been fun for me and the rest of
my life so to speak
has been i've been interested in just so
many other kinds of things
and um you know it was really good to
get to the point where i could
you know climb a fairly tall tower of
doing physics research
but then by golly i've learned about
azilean other fields since then
and that's been a lot of fun and i think
it's in the end even my big effort in
physics in recent times
has been made possible because i've
learned all these other things and now
those things can come back
to inform what i'm doing in physics um
so you know i think that
that for me at that time i was like i'm
mostly interested in just this one thing
of doing physics research
if i'd been interested in lots of things
i probably would have
found it really good to just hang out in
school for a long time
just taking classes and this and that
and the other thing and just learning
all kinds of
things but as it was i kind of
definitely knew i want to do this
you know okay fair enough by the time i
was 20 i was like okay i'm now
you know playing physics professor or
whatever and what am i going to do next
type thing and i and i did figure out a
little bit of an answer to that
um which was good um and uh you know i
think that um
uh but but as it was up to that time i
was very very very focused on this on
this one kind of goal
and i think that that if you're if
you're set up that way
then then by all means go do it um
if you're if you're like well i don't
really know if that's the goal if i want
to learn these kinds of things
you kind of have an opportunity when
you're young to just like learn all
kinds of stuff and nobody's really going
to ask you
why are you doing that what are you why
are you learning about this and that and
the other thing it's just like
people expect young people just go learn
about all kinds of things
and you kind of have a free pass to go
do that when you're older
it's not so easy to spend a bunch of
time learning about things i mean i
i kind of have a a sort of a cheat way
to do that which is i run a company
that uh you know is applies computation
builds tools that apply computation to
everything
which means i kind of have an excuse to
learn about pretty much
anything and um i've made use of that
as a as a as a you know i've made use of
that and chosen to learn about all these
kinds of things
but that's something not every you know
that's a
that's a rare kind of job that kind of
lets you have the excuse oh i'm going to
learn about chemistry today
i'm going to learn about you know
something about uh you know molecular
biology today
and those are things that are actually
important and contribute to
to the uh sort of the real work that i'm
doing
um
let's see i need to go
soon here um
well there are questions here and maybe
i should do a different one of these
kinds of sessions there are questions
here from
palmetti's great great screen name um
about um uh
various kinds of history questions and i
realized that i
i probably should do some some history q
a which perhaps will be less interesting
to the young and more interesting to
older
um uh the um
uh there's a question about
a course at mit that i've not heard of
so therefore i think i'm not don't know
about it
and uh you ask about dana scott i
actually happen to hear from him
day before yesterday um so
there's uh yeah lots of things i
um um let's see
um
somebody and this is indicating that uh
we don't just have kids on this
livestream rohit is commenting
the first computer he programmed was a
pdp-8
um yeah that that takes one back a bit
um
cool though um okay there's a question
here
i'm just gonna answer a couple more from
ozan
why is computational science not
spreading among high schools better
good question good question
you know there have been multiple waves
of people trying to sort of teach
computing in schools
starting in the 1960s you know basic was
a language that's actually pretty good
that was invented for
teaching kids logo another language logo
kind of
became scratch um you know
various other efforts here's what
happens
you know and we've been involved in this
and i think
we've been able to do some really
interesting things because with wolfram
language
and with our whole computational
language sort of
uh development you can get to the point
where you just use computation as a tool
to do whatever you're interested in you
know you're interested in
i don't know geography you can use it
because we have all this data about
geography you can immediately study you
know
questions about geographic questions
about you know which country has the
largest lakes or
whoever who knows what it is which um
you know which country has uh
uh which region of the world has the
most red in its flags or you know all
these kinds of questions
or you could answer a question you know
if you're interested in um
i don't know in chemistry you can answer
some question about that
and this is part of you can just do this
computationally and that's uniquely
become possible
with the things i've been building over
the last third of a century in wolfram
language
that's uniquely something that's
possible with our language
um what has happened is and there's
plenty that's being done
with sort of teaching uh computational
thinking and so on with with our
language
um and for people who are interested
like there's a little book that i wrote
and it's a mooc and things like that
called elementary introduction to wolf
language
which is a good place to start and those
kinds of things
um but uh you know that's a really good
idea and it works really well
and and i have kind of a a hobby project
of actually
trying it on the ground with actual kids
uh every week actually
um and uh that's my way of finding out
whether i know what i'm talking about
about whether this really works with
kids and
and uh um it uh it works really well
i recently i seem to have ended up um
uh it's a little bit harder to do in a
zoom
setting than it is um uh in person but
um
uh it works works really well um and
people
get to explore all kinds of really
interesting things
um and just using computation as a
vehicle for exploring things they're
interested in
not its computation as a means in itself
it's a little bit like when you learn
writing
you know you can just do classes where
you're just learning to write
you know running to write english or
whatever um but
at some point you have to start writing
about things or it becomes kind of
boring it's like how many exercises can
you do
where you're just abstractly writing
things we have to start writing about
things well you know kind of the whole
point of sort of having a computational
language
is it gives you a way to do computation
about
things and then you can do all kinds of
cool stuff and that's a really good
thing to do
with kids by kids etc etc etc
okay but then people get the idea we've
heard computing is important
we've heard that programming is what you
do when you do computing what is
programming
programming is writing those
instructions that tell a computer what
to do
oh you know you use a programming
language to do that
the programming language has variables
and loops and it has this and memory
locations
all that kind of thing well that's a
very different activity from using
computation to think about
how you solve a problem and and being a
and
having the computer automate away all of
those things about where's the memory
location what how do i allocate
you know how do i uh loop over this this
set of variables things like that
so but what people then think
programming and computing
is is this very low level thing that's
like how do i set
variable values for variables how do i
jump to this part of the program
all that kind of thing okay that
activity
is very fiddly and to many people very
boring
and i think that um you know i've
written uh you know
it's it's the whole point of having a
computer
i think is to let the computer do as
much as it can for you
rather than you kind of coming to it and
saying i'm going to tell you exactly
step by step how to do your thing as a
computer
it's like you have an idea it's the job
of the language designer
to let you as directly as possible
express your ideas so that a computer
can help you with it
and that's kind of what i've spent a
large part of my life doing
really no other group has been doing
this
this is sort of our our unique thing is
this idea of building this sort of
full-scale computational language to
express things computationally so it's
better it's always easier to explain to
people when you say
there are five things like the thing
that we've built but there aren't
it's just this one thing and uh you know
but that allows you to do this thing
of sort of thinking computationally and
using the computer
as your kind of assistant to explore the
world so to speak
very powerful thing to do what people
end up doing is teaching
coding which ends up being let's you
know
tell a computer at a low level what to
do okay
uh you know do people care about that uh
some people like it
some people like it a lot some people
are gonna be programmers
and that's fine um and the world needs
a certain number of those people people
like me try to automate
the the things which are kind of boring
to do so that you can do the interesting
things that only you know that
where it's a human telling the computer
what to do and the computer is
automating
doing all the details so to speak but
but it's like
so so you know it's kind of a question
of when you're teaching something
how far back do you go you know if
you're teaching
something like um oh i don't know um
uh well it comes up with math as well
but i mean if you're teaching
writing do you explain to people this is
how you create a pen
this is how you take a feather and slice
it and put it in ink
to make a pen to write with well no you
can just assume
you have a writing implement and you
just going to write stuff or
you know if you um you know there's a
question of what where do you start from
and this kind of going backwards and
starting from this very low level
things that are indeed what professional
systems programmers you know do
is is probably not the best thing to be
teaching kids so a lot of kids find it
kind of dull
and you know what's happened like with
math education
a lot of that has become very mechanical
and people find it kind of dull
and it's a shame because math is really
really interesting and i think it's
really interesting at least i think a
lot
of people would find it much more
interesting and much more compelling
if they weren't in the details of let's
mechanically do something
that actually we could get a computer to
do much better so
uh you know i think one of the problems
is that that um
sort of the coding type thing tends to
be kind of boring kind of mechanical
we are now in about the fifth iteration
of
people trying to teach coding in schools
and it seems to never really quite work
it's also the case that uh you know to
what extent should learning
uh computational things be like people
typically learn i don't know musical
instruments or something
not as part of the systematic schooling
story
but as rather as a as a kind of um
avocation
separate from that and to what extent
should be part of the main
sort of schooling thing there's also
issues like
um well you know i think the the things
that we've built with this kind of
computational language
um you know they should allow one
to really bring computation into
education um and but in the same kind of
way that writing is brought into
education
not as something where it's all a
writing class but writing is just
something you do
as part of other things that you're
learning about and i think there's a
certain
there's a certain level that you have to
get to with sort of writing at a certain
level you have to get to with
computational language
so that you can go and use it for other
things but that's kind of the pattern
that should be followed
um and that will really work and one of
these years one of these decades that's
how people will learn
um you know it's kind of interesting
because you know we basically
i've been involved for a long time in
building the technology for this
the mechanics of how you actually inject
it into the school system
that's a big complicated mess because
there's a complicated ecosystem of
well you know if you're going to put in
a school there's lots of things kids
have to learn because after all
there are these exams they have to take
and the exams test them on this and that
and the other
and oh this isn't something the exams
test them in but they say well why
aren't there exams that test them in
this well that's because
people aren't learning this yet so it's
a kind of chicken egg complicated cycle
in some countries that cycle has been
more successfully
kind of broken i mean one of the things
that's a little bit shocking to realize
is you know public education you know
where
where there's a sort of the government
provides educational uh
for for people is a hundred and
something years old
in most countries some a little bit less
some a little bit more but it's about
100 years old
maybe a hundred and what is it 140 years
old maybe
um well so
one of the things that's really
interesting is this idea of computation
it's the first really fundamental really
broad idea
that has come into existence since the
beginning of public education
so you know everything else reading
writing arithmetic type thing
they all existed before when public
education was first invented
but computational thinking did not exist
at that time
and the question is is it possible is it
even possible for something new to be
introduced
into something that's had this
century-long kind of uh
sort of development one hopes so
otherwise it's people learning things
sort of independent of school i mean one
of the things to realize that people may
know this but
but you know many of the hot shot
programmers
out there they didn't learn to program
in school they just learned to program
and uh it's not they didn't take a class
in it
they took no classes in it often but
they're really good programmers
and they built really big systems and
and so on
um but it's something where it's like
you know the the
what you do in school is not necessarily
that connected
to what you're able to do uh you know as
a practitioner of these kinds of things
um all right i think i have to wrap up
here
um and uh um
thanks for dropping in i think we we've
been um
uh i say we my team has been um
uh chopping up some of these some uh
some of these q a sessions and turning
them into podcasts
so if you're interested in in questions
other than the ones we talked about
today
you might find some of them answered in
some of those podcast episodes
all right well thanks for coming and
see you next week bye